so I'm happy to be with you today to
talk to you about our experience with a
new diagnostic test in our emergency
department last year so with that I like
to send my appreciation to lab roots and
the invitation for being here today I
have one disclosure some of the data
that we're going to show you today was
supported by an unrestricted edge
investigator initiated unrestricted
educational grant from Roche to generate
some of the data that we use in our
emergency department last year so the
purpose of today's talk is really to
look at five distinct areas to discuss
why influenza is always a discussion for
both clinical laboratory communities and
hospital networks each year why do we
continue to hear issues about influenza
what options are available for testing
in influenza series rapid tests
molecular tests panel tests where do
these new diagnostic frontiers capture
in the clinical diagnostic community and
there is a new option for influenza
testing this year that we'd like to
introduce you to to test system that we
had some experience with last year
called the Roche Co Bastiat that we'll
introduce you to but beyond that really
what we're going to focus on here today
is the theoretical question of whether
or not testing can impact patient
management particularly in the emergency
department setting and share with you
some of our experiences we like to think
as laboratory ins that the testing that
we offer has a direct impact to patient
care
so we'd like to explore that discussion
a little further and finally to talk
about testing and impacting outcomes in
this modern day of health care
management where we spend our money and
how we spend our money wisely with
diagnostic tests that can really impact
outcome of patients is a key area of
discussion going forward so with that
I'd like to introduce you to the
influenza virus each year we get
influenza that occurs in distinct
outbreaks varying extent every year the
epidemiological pattern of the influenza
reflects the changes in natures of
antigen etic properties of the virus and
the subsequent spread and virulence that
we see each year of influenza is
directly related to some of the
transmissibility properties as these
virus shift so every year as laboratory
and communities we gear up for flu
season we talk about extending coverage
of testing to help our healthcare
systems we look at it and typically when
we talk about influenza we'll see a
figure like this that is put up here
schematic of the virus and we know that
each year influenza remains a moving
target both for Diagnostics as well as
therapeutic as well as vaccine
development because we know our virus
shifts we know that the antigen etic
properties of the virus the virulence
that we see the diagnostic capabilities
of detecting the virus are often
dependent on changes that we see in
surface proteins particularly
hemagglutinin and neuraminidase changes
to hemagglutinin allow different viruses
to bind to silac rasa drew scepters on
epithelial cells in different fashions
we know that our molecular tests target
largely matrix proteins inside the virus
but it's those changes to the virus each
year that give us some of the discussion
points going forward to talk about
influenza when we see my small minor
changes small minor mutational events
that occur in the virus we refer to
those as antigen etic drift when we see
large reassortment of the viruses and
the so called terminologies that we hear
h1n1 as example h1 and 5 when we see
large reassortment of the viruses within
human and animal communities then we
refer to that as antigen etic antigen
etic drift and all of these properties
come together to allow us to be able to
look at the way in which we treat
patients diagnosed and and protect
patients against influenza every year
whoops I went back slide so moving
forward it's interesting to note that
this is a slide published last year in
MMWR looking at the influenza rates the
epidemic rates that we had seen over the
last five years when we calculate
epidemic thresholds epidemiologists will
look at mortality rates of the virus as
represented by largely 1.6 standard
deviations above a mortality rate that
represents a threshold and what you can
see is that over the last four or five
seasons we've had distinct patterns in
which the
fluenta season has reached epidemic
thresholds this puts tremendous pressure
both on health care community's health
care systems as well as diagnostic labs
to meet the demand for incoming flu
seasons
we know that incidence rates this is
some of our own local data provided to
us by our great state Department of
Health in the state of Minnesota looking
at some of the incidence rates that we
had seen over the last few years last
year in particular 2014-2015 was a
particularly large year for the state of
Minnesota and many of you have had
similar experiences where you get calls
from emergency department from pediatric
settings saying that we're seeing a lot
of flu so the theoretical questions of
why tests for flu often come up and
we're gonna circle round to this but we
do hear these discussions during the
height of flu season if a patient
presents to the emergency department or
to an outpatient clinic with signs of
fever and signs of symptoms of influenza
it's probably influenza why do we need
to test for flu and these are just some
of the issues this discussion points to
talk about we know that testing for flu
can help guide treatment courses we know
that antibiotics are often over
administered in cases when they
shouldn't be and we want to be able to
be judicious in the use of antivirals
that we provide for upcoming flu seasons
the CDC has numerous recommend
recommendations for who gets antiviral
treatment and there's large debate over
these we know that over the years there
have been some debates over who gets the
antiviral treatments what cohorts should
we look at it for we truthfully probably
don't give enough antivirals to patients
that we see but you can see some of the
populations that we see here severe are
complicated courses those requiring
hospitalization those at extreme age
groups long-term care facilities amino
suppressive therapies those of specific
ethnic origins these are all
recommendations by the CDC to help guide
treatment for flu we also know that
testing definitively for flu can help
support empiric antibiotic coverage for
admitted patients we hope that it can
help guide admission and discharge
changes in orders and we hope that
influenza Diagnostics can help guide
subsequent procedures if we can
definitively identify influenza and
provide a diagnosis does it prevent
test orders lab orders and even
procedures imaging and things like that
we know it's helpful to the medical
staff in helping to predict course as
well as with any diagnostic modality we
know that if we can help to predict a
course and with the diagnosis that it's
helpful to families in the communities
so we know that there are a number of
reasons to test for influenza to help
predict cohorting and hospitals and it's
useful for patients to know as well so
there are a number of reasons to test
for flu but again we come back to this
central issue does any of the testing
that we do make a difference and that's
going to be a central theme going
forward so there are many things that we
can do in the clinical laboratory
testing is one of them this is just one
of the photos that I saw last year at a
local grocery store that I thought I'd
share with you we all have our part in
helping with influenza season this is
just one of them but beyond that in the
laboratory we clearly have an armament
now of ways to test for influenza virus
new tools that are disposable that we
frankly have never had before from the
large multiplex viral panels to PCR
based tests to the new generation of
rapid assays to our point of care
deliveries to even cell culture and
Direct fluorescent antigen based tests
what is the proper way to test for flu
remains a theoretical discussion and is
largely dependent on variables that
influence one's own healthcare system
but this is just some of the armament
that is at our disposal for how we test
for flu when one looks at the data we
can see that not all testing is
equivalent this was a study performed a
few years ago by Christine Gino Keo in
New York looking at the sensitivities in
2009 again this was the height of the
h1n1 outbreak of some of the rapid tests
that were at there in their disposal at
the time of looking at it and you can
see that not all tests performed equally
the other thing that you note is that
it's very difficult to argue for testing
that meets a minimum sensitivity bar
below 50% it's very difficult to argue
for that testing and part of the reason
I'm showing this slide is this slide was
really a key Sentinel slide in my career
in terms of being able to advocate for a
way of the use of the rapids on campus
I've since come a little bit softer and
full circle on the use
some of the newer generation rapid
assays but you can see that not all
testing is performed equal well what
about the use of the rapid panel tests
the comprehensive tests that can look
for 16-17 in some cases 21 different
circulating respiratory viruses these
assays clearly have a role in our
diagnostic armamentarium and we use them
for our inpatient admissions our
transplant units are areas in which we
need to know definitively the
circulating virus composition
independent in a potential patient this
is just one additional publication done
by Melissa Miller's group in the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
looking at some of the sensitivity of
some of the multiplex panel based
testing in this series they looked at
sensitivity as a comparison of two of
the three positive nucleic acid tests
that could detect an assay detective
virus and once again you see that these
test platforms perform very well but you
can notice that it takes time to get
these results and the actionable events
on being able to diagnose influenza
virus when the patient is in front of
you is limited by the use of these tests
so the debate over the ideal influenza
test i've used this quote borrowed this
quote stole this quote from some
colleagues of mine who have published on
cdf related issues but we're reminded
from wyatt earp that fast is fine but
accuracy is everything and we're really
looking for diagnostic assays that can
provide us with an actionable event with
a standalone result that we know is
definitive so over the years the testing
and the debate for the ideal influenza
test has typically been a balance
between sensitivity and speed over the
last few years that debate has typically
debated over how much are we willing to
pay as not only laboratories but as
healthcare systems for the access to the
speed of that testing and where that
testing is more or less likely to result
in actionable events I'm putting this
slide up here just as a reminder this is
the CDC's guidance to professionals to
clinician guidance for algorithms for
looking at the way in which we determine
the use of rapid influenza testing and
you can see from this figure here that
they're basically letting us know that
where the test is
and where the test is negative that we
should be looking at signs and symptoms
once again advocating for the use of the
clinical direction because we know some
of our rapid tests have historically
lacked the sensitivity that we've come
to expect from the larger core
laboratory facilities who can offer the
testing so that brings us to the point
of the new test that we like to show you
now this is a new test on the market
some of you have heard of this test the
Kobus Liat test and this is a new test
presented by Roche the next few slides
are courtesy of Roche provided to me
from Roche to kind of elaborate and
illustrate what the test is so the test
is a standalone analyzer it is a
molecular true cycling PCR that actually
cycles in a molecular platform a
pencil-sized flexible tube is inserted
into the instrument the tube can only go
into one directional unidirectional we
fill it up with the viral transport
media that we use to inoculate the tube
that we collect from from suspension the
interesting thing about this assay is
that this assay uses a actuator with all
chemicals stored onboard that allow us
to be able to cycle at a very very rapid
rate that rate allows us to be able to
offer a molecular test a reverse
transcriptase PCR for influenza virus in
less than a 25 minute less than a 30
minute threshold the analytical test
time for detection of influenza on the
instrument is approximately 20 to 22
minutes and it's this actuation process
that allows the cooling and thermal
cycling processes to really be sped up
to the point where it can break that
30-minute threshold for those of you
that know what I'm talking about when we
brought about molecular tests we often
think about cycles of molecular tests
and historically we've been looking at
one degrade per ampere degree per second
that sounds very technical what are we
talking about well for for a typical
forty to forty five cycle or thirty to
thirty five cycle assay we're typically
restricted to one minute per cycle which
typically allows our molecular assays to
be offered at somewhere around that 35
45 50 minute threshold this technology
allows us to speed that process up quite
substantially
it's got heating and cooling elements
controlled temperatures um
sensors in the assay that are all preset
the optical system then can read
individual channels for both an
influenza A and influenza B target as
well as an internal control that is all
onboard in the test the test is fully
complete it packs everything that you
need to be able to run the PCR reaction
it's one-stop closed tube system that
includes all the magnetic bead based
extractions the lysis buffer is the
protonates k the aleutian buffers and
all the PCR reagents required to do PCR
all in a flexible platform single tube a
device the company currently has claims
for both strep a as well as influenza A
and B on the system so the key question
that I want to keep circling down to is
can access to rapid reliable molecular
based influenza testing in the emergency
department change practice management so
when we heard about access to this test
we can't we contracted some of the folks
through the independent grant
association that Roche carries to be
able to look at a grant that would allow
us to sample the use of the test in a
high-throughput emergency department
setting a Hennepin County Medical Center
has a very large very well known
national emergency medicine to program
emergency medicine department we see
roughly 110,000 DD visits a year and we
thought it would be a good opportunity
to look at the use of modern
contemporary Diagnostics so we got
together a group that we formed into a
study that we referred to as the clade
study the clinical decision making in
the emergency department setting using
the use of this test at the patient
centered level so we are fortunate
enough to have a laboratory an emergency
department laboratory it's run under the
larger laboratory CLIA license many of
you have an emergency department or a
satellite lab associated with your
emergency department we looked at it
over three months during the 2015 season
in approximately 314 patient visits we
were fortunate enough to be able to tap
into the medical students and the
residents that are associated with our
Hospital in University of Minnesota that
allowed us to incorporate a 24/7 study
enrollment the best way to interpret
whether or not a test
is actually making a difference in
actionable events for a physician is to
simply ask them so our medical students
and residents were fortunate enough to
feed them and provide them with the
opportunity to be involved in a study
were able to admission administer a five
page survey to the admitting physician
when a patient came in we had a hundred
and fifty patients enrolled in the
series that provided a in addition to
the history and physical a detailed
study five page survey was administered
that ask the provider very key specific
questions what is the likelihood of flu
in your patient what symptoms does your
patient have what is your initial
management course are you going to give
them antipyretics are you going to admit
them are you going to give them imaging
are you gonna order chest films are you
gonna provide anti microbials are you
going to give them Tamiflu very specific
pointed questions related to their
history and physical exam that we could
track the changes that were made in
patient management as a result of the
test so as the study was that being
administered and the survey was being
given
we were running the influenza test in
the emergency department clinical lab we
included cases that met our 45-minute
bar window which allowed us to look at
150 patients when the test result from
the lab came back the same provider that
provided the initial history and
physical and provided the initial
assessment was given a follow-up survey
and asked did the result of rapid
influenza test change anything on your
management and test characteristics of
the assay were performed compared to the
gen mark assay to look at all the
analytics that the lab community likes
to look at sensitivity specificity but
we were really interested in looking at
is whether or not the clinicians could
document changes as a result in
management of their patients as a result
of the test now it's important to know
that all of the changes that were
documented by the provider in the second
follow-up survey had to be traceable to
the electronic medical record I'm not a
big fan of survey based studies because
anybody can frankly do them and they're
often biased the og dr. Hansen is a good
guy I know a few people in the emergency
department I'll click YES on his serve
and so we needed to track that any
changes that a provider noted could be
traced directly to the medical record
what do I mean by that well if a
provider said I'm going to admit the
patient because I'm very concerned about
the influenza status and the patient and
the test result came back and was
influenza negative and the provider
decided well I think you could probably
go home we don't probably need to admit
you based on your influenza status that
change had to be documented in epic we
needed to be able to go which is our
electronic medical record we needed to
be able to go back into the electronic
medical record and see the initial order
for an antibiotic an antiviral and
admission and then see that order
changed in order to count it in our
study so how do we know how test has an
impact these are some of the questions
that were asked to the providers upon
the initial presentation of the patient
in the emergency department with
influenza-like symptoms we asked about
the clinical suspicion for flu we asked
about the clinical symptoms does your
patient have fever do we see hemoptysis
do we see some of these issues that
associate with the influenza like
illness what is on your history and
physical differential what else is
included in your in your differential
other than influenza does this person
have an exacerbation of COPD what is
your initial care and plan for the
patient are you going to administer
therapy are you going to administer
procedures and do you plan to admit the
patient when the test result returned a
pointed series of 15 targeted questions
were asked to providers based on the
initial assessment this is just some of
the questions that were asked did the
insult of the influenza test change your
management will an admission discharge
order be changed will the patient
receive anti therapeutic agents in a
different form now will you add
additional lab tests will you d see
additional lab tests to get an
indication of how the tests being
delivered in a fashion within a 40 45
minute time frame could impact
management of influenza patients in the
emergency department setting and this is
some of our results what we noticed was
that in a hundred and fifty documented
patients we saw changes in patient
management in almost 60
percent of the cases 50% of the time the
providers noted a change that could be
documented to the electronic medical
record as a result of having access to
rapid influenza testing in the emergency
department setting the other thing
that's somewhat interesting but probably
not surprising to the laboratory
community is that over half of those
cases in which a management change
occurred in a patient were as a result
of a negative influenza test and there's
lots of discussion these days about
point of care for microbiology about
where we are likely to best
operationalize our resources our limited
resources in healthcare dollars in
laboratory expenditure and in laboratory
personnel but the best candidate for a
test in which we can make an argument
for is a test that has clinical decision
points resulting on both positive and
negative test results so what this
figure shows here is that over half 61%
of the cases in which a management
change was documented occurred as a
result of confidence in a negative
influenza test result so what were the
changes that we had seen and what were
the changes that were documented by the
providers recordable in the electronic
medical record
well not surprisingly 53% of the
documented changes to antiviral
antimicrobial stewardship occurred the
way that we use our anti-infective
agents is largely dependent on the
accuracy and the timeliness in which the
laboratory can deliver diagnostic
results for infectious related issues
17% of our changes also occurred in
changes to admission order sets either
patients were not going to be initially
admitted or they were going to be
initially admitted and the result of the
influenza test in conjunction with the
larger clinical picture allowed
providers to change order sets for
admission or discharge and we'll talk
about the significance of that finding
in a few slides nineteen percent of the
changes that we saw occurred in changes
to procedures in the lab as you can see
sometimes this goes both ways if we
diagnose influenza sometimes it results
in additional tests being or
where now we have additional chest films
being ordered because we're concerned
about pneumonia so there are 19 percent
of the cases that we saw we saw changes
to put additional procedures and
additional orders we have one case in
our series four note in which the
differential included meningitis on a 14
year old girl that came into the
emergency department upon testing for
influenza the clinical team decided that
the positive influenza result probably
negated a spinal tap on that individual
so you can see the cascade of events
that occur as the result of access to
positive and negative test results in
the system I mentioned this before that
this is an example of one of the figures
from the CDC's initiative to healthcare
providers of how to deal with influenza
during the influenza season and you can
see here that this is a question that
we've asked is can clinical symptoms
impression alone diagnose influenza with
any degree of accuracy why do we need
laboratory testing at all we hear it
every year from colleagues from
providers from guideline based
approaches if a patient presents with
influenza like illness the likelihood
during flu season that that person has
flu is probably pretty strong do we
really even need testing at all to be
able to diagnose influenza and you can
see even with the guidance from the CDC
based on some of the difficulties with
the rapid test results the actionable
events are to use clinical signs and
symptoms and history as information with
which patient management approaches will
continue for patients that have
influenza so a philosophical question
would be if we added up all these
clinical symptoms alone how well would
providers do in diagnosing influenza
well because our survey asked that
question directly what is the likelihood
that your patient has influenza we were
actually able to go back and chart that
and what we found was when providers
indicated that this patient fell into a
very high risk and I think the
probability of this patient having
influenza based on clinical symptoms
alone was high it turns out they were
right
thirty-six percent of the time we know
that looking at fever gave us a clinical
sensitivity during last year's flu
season of only thirty percent and that
the clinical sensitivity of no fever was
almost identical so what does all of
this data mean does this mean that
providers are only 36 percent sensitive
and diagnosing flu from clinical
symptoms alone well there's lots of
debates to have from this but it's
interesting to remember our experience
in our study of 36 percent sensitivity
because that number is exactly the same
as a very recent publication done out of
Johns Hopkins that looked at the exact
same issue when they looked at back and
looked at the clinicians perspective of
the clinical diagnosis and how well the
clinical diagnosis correlated to an
entire ocean of influenza based on a
gold standard of lab testing sensitivity
36% is the exact same number that we
found in our series so it's food for
thought it's pause for caution perhaps
that the clinical symptoms that we're
seeing each year with changes in
influenza status really are difficult
for providers in very high-risk areas
and very large areas where we're trying
to triage patients through with any
degree of accuracy uncertainty in this
series here the ili the influenza like
case definition was less sensitive than
the clinical diagnosis but still did not
approach 50% so our experience the raw
laboratory analytical experience we're
still kind of debating some of the the
correlative data of this there's a
couple discrepant we're looking at but
we had 314 cases that we were able to
analyze a hundred and fifty of those
cases met our patient criteria for being
able to have clinical documentation
changes tracked through the electronic
medical record but we have 314 cases in
which we looked at the Kobus layout over
flu season last year including eighty to
positive three of them we used the gen
mark our VP panel
dr. Miller as I showed earlier in a
slide has previously shown that that
panel is a very sensitive very specific
assay on the market and you can see that
any time you do a comparative study
there's a couple of stragglers that we
have to
work out here we're still in the process
of looking at those to see whether or
not those are sample distribution issues
if we would just split the specimen too
many times or whether or not there was
actually influenza RNA in the sample but
the sensitivity of our assay performed
very well the sensitivity of the package
insert from the manufacturers is shown
before as well where we can see
sensitivity of a hundred and percent for
both flu a and flu B it's also important
to note the strong sensitivity of flu B
historically many of the assays on the
market including ones that I've used in
our practice have faltered with
sensitivities of flu B flu B often
becomes a more difficult diagnostic
target to look at it's also potentially
a more difficult treatment target to
look at as well there's a number of very
well done series including a very well
done study in Tokyo looking at the
efficacy of the antiviral treatment for
influenza B and a statistically lower
and clinically significant lower rate
than we see for influenza A so when you
look at sensitivity of the assays that
you're looking at influenza A and
influenza B sensitivity is important to
understand the impact of Co circulating
viruses is also a hot topic we've
learned much about the role of Co
circulating viruses we thought we'd
share this with you we found a
respiratory virus which included flu but
a respiratory virus in over half percent
over fifty three percent of all of the
cases we encountered in the emergency
department last year so we are starting
to see the impact of some of these
circulating virus a slide like this
points to the value of being able to
understand what viruses are actually
present in our very very sick patients
are very compromised patients are
transplant patients the influenza virus
was detected in forty-four of all of the
cases we encountered and a second
respiratory virus was detected in over a
quarter of all of the cases we had seen
the the II D physicians involvement in
the assay and in diagnostic testing is
really important as well and so we were
able to go back prospectively and ask
the providers in real-time about the
satisfaction of the test
they were looking at satisfaction is
becoming kind of a hot term we're
looking at it in regards to patient
satisfaction but also provider
satisfaction in terms of the services
that we deliver from the lab not
surprisingly we had a very strong
support of the test in our emergency
department what's really interesting to
me about the patient satisfaction
responses are the cases in which we
found providers were not happy with the
tests
most of those incidences were around
cases in which the test result could not
be delivered within the 35 to 45 minute
period and it's one thing to keep in
mind as we bring tests like this into
our environment is that most of these
are single box tests that require us to
put one sample in at a time so when we
look at the way in which we deliver
influenza testing in our communities and
in our practice we need to be cognizant
of surge capacity and the ability for us
to get assays on the market and get
samples through that meet certain
degrees of volume that we were expect to
see in certain areas so what does all
this mean we talked about the analytical
sensitivity we talked about the value of
testing we even showed you some of the
data that proved that the testing that
we had performed in the emergency
department last year had clinically
actionable events but there are two key
questions that need to be asked the
first is is what is the effect of all
this testing on our healthcare dollar
dollars and is smarter expenditure
really a solution so I'm going to give
you a little bit of insight into some
data that we're continuing to mine as
part of our study that we hope to be
able to present at the Association for
molecular pathology meeting in a couple
of months we know from some very large
studies done and funded by the AHRQ that
have looked at the costs for hospital
stays in the United States this is a
very difficult slide to read but this
little purple arrow here highlights the
fact that we're seeing positive
admissions increases in admission for
patients that have codes for pneumonia
and we're seeing pneumonia become a
larger larger issue in our hospital
systems over the last couple years we
know that there's almost a seven percent
increase
in hospital stays that include a
diagnosis of pneumonia from an emergency
department setting so there are a number
of ways in which hospitals bill and
recoup costs associated with pneumonia
we also know from another very well done
AHRQ document that the average cost of
admitting somebody with a simple
diagnosis of pneumonia that would
exclude TB that would exclude HIV a
simple diagnosis of pneumonia from an
emergency department setting typically
costs a healthcare organization about
$10,000 a diagnosis we know that there
are a number of DRG codes that we can
apply to diagnosis to allow hospital
systems to be able to recoup costs
associated with a initial diagnostic
grouping code the complexity of these
codes add various values to what
hospitals are essentially allowed to
charge allowed to bill and you can see
some of the numbers here but some of
them you clearly note that what we can
recoup is less than what the AHRQ is
established as the principal diagnosis
of pneumonia if we're costing the cost
of a hospital bed is $10,000 for the
simple admission and we can only recoup
$5,000 of that you can see that it's
costing us more money in this current
healthcare climate to treat patients
than what hospitals can recoup so where
does this all come in well this is some
data that we're working on with a
healthcare economics group to look at
healthcare anomic s-- economics outcomes
associated with the data set that we
were able to generate but just to show
you superficially some of the incidents
that we're looking at is we're looking
at the use of tests as cost aversion
cost diversion tools in our total
healthcare dollars where can we
reallocate healthcare dollars in a more
clinically responsible financially
responsible fashion
we know that the simple cost of the
diagnosis for pneumonia is about $10,000
a case in the 65 days we performed our
analysis 15 documented cases were seen
where hospital admission changes were
changed where we would have admitted a
patient but that patient was now
discharged
as part of the larger clinical picture
including the access to the rapid
influenza result if you just do some
simple math you start to see how the
numbers start to generate where you can
potentially look at a cost diversion of
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
65 days in a very high emergency
department high throughput high incident
season of influenza we also know that
the core the ability to judiciously use
our antivirals and anti-infective also
has a role every Hospital now likely has
antimicrobial stewardship committees
that have been gathered that have been
mandated in many cases by CMS by Jayco
by regulatory authorities to look at the
way in which anti microbials are
provided and given and used at
healthcare facilities so the ability for
Diagnostics tests to either confirm or
support the original use of
anti-infective z' is important as well
and we estimate that 33 cases of Tamiflu
fact we documented 33 cases of Tamiflu
were deseed in our in our 65 day trial
with use of the test which had a cost
diversion of over another three thousand
dollars so we're looking at the ways in
which testing can help with cost
diversion in in our overall healthcare
dollars so the summary and conclusions
we know that rapid access to sensitive
flu testing in the emergency department
environment was associated with changes
in patient management's to both a
clinically significant and a
statistically significant level we know
that 53 percent of the documented
changes we observed in our series
involve changes to anti-infective
treatment and the changes in admission
and discharge orders accounted for 17%
of all the evaluable cases but those 17%
were the largest cost diversions that we
could have obtained in our series and
that 23% of all the documented changes
in initial management occurred as a
result of access to rapid flu testing so
the colbus lea assay truly represents a
rapid sensible sensitive adaptable assay
for the delivery of influenza results
that can impact patient care it's
somewhat ironic that for the last decade
laborat
communities have been clamoring for a
rapid adaptable molecular standalone
result box standalone assay that would
allow us to deliver testing in
clinically actionable events closer to
patients and now we have one on the
market so my final thoughts as we get to
the end of this presentation are just to
talk about the philosophical barriers of
point-of-care applications for influenza
testing there's no question that the
delivery of healthcare and our current
climate is about to change we're looking
at models that are based on preventative
medicine rather than to have people
present to our hospitals in many cases
if people present to our emergency
departments we've done a bad job can we
prevent actionable events in larger
settings outside of the traditional
models of where we typically looked at
where testing is done
ie a core centralized molecular or
microbiology laboratory and to remind us
of where we've come and the potential of
where we might go we look back to the
early 90s of where we were with
point-of-care testing and post
anesthesia care units as a result of
access to blood gases two sodium's to
potassium and very well done studies
that showed that the analytical
transport time really was a barrier in
terms of being able to deliver accurate
results to patients historically from
microbiology our barrier and our bar has
been our familiarity and our comfort
level with the sensitivity and the
specificity of the testing that we
allowed to leave the laboratory but
these discussions are worth having
there's lots of testing there's plenty
of testing to go around the discussions
of we're testing is more likely to
provide actionable events our key
discussion points going forward for both
the laboratory but specifically the
microbiology community going forward so
the final thoughts is access to testing
enough to impact patient outcome it's
the integration of test results with the
physician at the bedside at the level at
which the history and the physical is
being provided that really provided
actionable events in our series in order
for point of care to provide a tangible
clinical
its results should be actionable and
used to make decisions which lead to
improve healthcare outcome and systems
like the Kobus Li I offer us the
potential of offering us testing in
areas in which we'd historically been
limited I'm citing a very very
well-known quote by Harry galas and the
folks in the University of North
Carolina over well over 20 years ago
1999 in which the authors noted that
central to the concept of empiric
management is uncertainty regarding the
diagnosis the role that we have in the
laboratory to help be part of the larger
clinical picture to impact patient care
is a real role and our data set proves
that that the data that's delivered from
the laboratory is used to make clinical
decision and the data that's provided by
laboratory ins makes a difference so
with that the barriers to implementation
are probably a discussion point to be
had in a separate discussion what is the
cost of this testing how do we look at
surge capacity where did we see testing
evolving from but clearly our experience
has shown us that the actionable events
in the emergency department with access
to rapid influenza testing changed
practice management so with that we feel
we've got a new test on the market a new
system on the market that offers us of
advantage we've never had before in the
fight against influenza there are many
ways to tackle influenza and now we
believe we have another diagnostic tool
on the forefront so with that I want to
thank everybody for their time their
discussions and allowing me to share our
data set with you today thank you very
much